moi j'ai deux filles je voudrais quand
même pas des phases du vélo pour le
cyclisme féminin c'est magnifique
[Musique]
en séries du cyclisme féminin
on va certainement c'est un excellent
sport ça entretient la ligne je suis pas
d'accord collé collé fanfare au fond du
hall d pensez-vous du cyclisme féminin
mais je trouve ça c'est bizarre comme
question posée à preignan fin c'est une
distraction mais ça peut pas être une
compétition pour les femmes je trouve
que c'est aujourd'hui ou jamais entendu
parler du coeur pourtant mon père il
fait du vélo n'ont jamais entendu parler
on voit jamais à la télé je pense que
les femmes ont tout autant droit de
faire du cyclisme que les hommes sur le
pont serait qu'on s'attendait pas
vraiment le cyclisme est un des sports
qui est essentiel c'est un sport
masculin je pense excellence ya pas de
sport réservé aux hommes ou aux femmes
il ya le sport est une pratique selon
ses envies ses capacités son talent
c'est tout ce qu'on sait que ça ne leur
ôte pas tr min
absolument pas jeune fille sur un vélo
c'est pas tellement gracieux pour le 100
m maintenant j'espère que ma femme ne
verra pas la vidéo mais je trouve ça
super sexy devoir me faire du vélo c'est
magnifique
est-ce que vous pensez que ça ne leur
ôte pas un peu de féminité non vraiment
pas c'est inesthétique serait pas
féminin du tout et pour les gens je
pense que ce soit vrai pour les jambes
je trouve que ça une femme gay trop
moche mais c'est pas bien et pour les
jambes
vous ne pensez pas que ce soit mauvais
état je vois pas pourquoi ce serait
mauvais pour les jambes au contraire je
pense que ça draine le sombre je pense
que c'est bon goût - pour la lutte
contre les varices je pense que les gens
ont tout intérêt à en faire toujours pas
en faire
si on parce qu'à ce moment là bien
entendu il ya un trop gros développement
des muscles qui nuit à l'esthétique
non c'est très bon pour les langues je
comprends pas vos questions
[Musique]